so a few weeks back here on this program
telling me you thought around about five
cabinet ministers would go for the leave
side well mystic fox well if you're very
good I might give you some of the
lottery numbers for next week the yes
and I think it was always very clear
that some ministers simply would not be
able to tolerate whatever deal was was
reached because they regarded it as such
an important issue of tremendous
substance that they were long committed
Michael Gove being one of them Chris
Grayling being another of those who just
fundamentally believe that Britain would
be better off outside the EU whatever
the terms of the renegotiation you must
be disappointed about the likes of Sajid
Javid not coming across your tally must
have told you that he was at the very
least sitting on the fence yes sir he
wasn't one of my five so I wasn't that
surprised in the end but of course you
know we're all still friends and we'll
work together for after the referendum
for what's best for the country but this
isn't a judgment that we have to take a
high-profile judgment about our
constitutional future as a country and I
think the one of the reasons that I
think that I know you've been having a
lot of this debate and I'm not privy
incidentally to this but I wonder
reasons I think the Boris Johnson will
choose to campaign for the out side in
the leaf side and the referendum is this
issue of sovereignty because I think for
a lot of people that were looking to see
you know where does the power ultimately
lie to make our laws and sovereignty is
about who has precedence in terms of the
law and the agreement that was reached
and I hate to sound technical about this
but the agreement that was reached on
so-called ever closer union was an
agreement between the heads of
government that does not outweigh treaty
the European Court of Justice will
ultimately look at treaty and say that
is what actually we'll make it happen
now we may get me know about the mayor
of london's concerns about Larissa yes
post them in the House of Commons though
but what are your contacts with him done
just like many of my other colleagues
I'm very friendly with him I'm having
dinner with them later this week so it
was nothing remarkable about all of this
but I think it is but just honest
decision would it be a big surprise to
you if he does not support that
leave campaign yes I'd be surprised
because I think it is all about this
point of sovereignty and the prime
minister says Britain is now free from
every closer Union I don't think that
stands up to legal scrutiny because i
think that the European Court will still
say the agreement you reach this week
says it's in accordance with EU treaties
we're not getting any treaty change the
only way you can actually change the
treaty is through the EU treaty
amendment procedure that didn't happen
and that means the European Court will
look at what the minister said this week
the heads of government but they do not
have to take it into account and for
many conservatives that would be the
crucial point because it means we
ultimately do not make our laws they're
determined overseas but I mean this
questions got to be asked about the
Conservative Party if you do get Boris
Johnson taking on the sitting Prime
Minister conservative prime minister of
the day this is going to be like the
political version of one of those
superhero movies or Godzilla versus King
Kong where they they fight themselves
across the major cities of the world
leave them all destroyed and you end up
with your party in tatters a decision
has been made about the European Union
but one of them presumably must fall
well I don't go back to this personality
argument you know I completely respect
take base well I completely respect what
the Prime Minister was trying to do he
was trying to get a better deal that
would enable us to stay within the
European Union that's not what I wanted
in the first place I wanted to leave the
European Union but for me what was
interesting about that was that the
process actually became the story that
we had a British Prime Minister going
Ryan with what I described as the
political begging bowl asking lots of
small countries that we actively
subsidize through our contributions to
the EU if it was okay for Britain to
change some of our welfare laws I don't
think we should have to do that and that
is my fundamental principle and i think
that the arguments need to stay on the
substance we must get away from if you
don't mind me saying the westminster
bubble portraying politics as
entertainment we need to get away from
your entertainment because it's such an
important issue must ask people who
articulate the arguments and you know
the Prime Minister is the best one to
articulate the argument in terms of the
renegotiation that he's been pretty but
you were the only person like yourself
and Boris Johnson a very very qualified
to talk to us about issues sovereignty
I'm fine so there are many other people
outside outside politics who will take a
view on these and who need to be
listened to people who are involved in
our security arrangement in in defense
in foreign policy they all need to be
heard and what I think what I'm really
saying is I don't really think it should
be turned into if personality ending
it's not wanna go there is indeed about
the issues but it's also about that
leadership side of things and if you get
the result you want do you really would
you really have confidence in the Prime
Minister as the man who wanted to see
the opposite result then leaving all
that technical process of taking the UK
out of the EU do not think that his
heart wouldn't really be in it well the
question here is are we Democrats or are
we not Democrats the public will give
their view and they will have everybody
watching your program will have the same
ability to change that results are as we
will have because they all have the same
voters we do when the public have made
the decision it's up to the politicians
to accept the will of the people if they
feel they cannot accept the will of the
people and implement what the British
public want then clearly the can't serve
in the government that will your
decision for them to take after we've
been through this process in the
referendum and it will be very
passionate and you know a lot of
friendships will be tested in this but
in the end we'll have to come back
together to govern the country we will
still be the majority party just just
all those friendships being tested what
he make a further like to George
Galloway as supporting the result you on
the sea well I'm sure there'll be all
sorts of people that wouldn't normally
be my political friends our allies in
that and they'll have their own reasons
for doing so actually his reasons are
diametrically opposed to my both be
right he thinks leaving me you would
turn Britain into a socialist paradise
yeah I think I've course think that's
completely wrong because I think there's
no chance of a selecting Jeremy Corbyn
as prime minister but let let's partner
for a moment but on both sides and you
know people say or how could you be in
the same campaign as as you know George
Galloway or and others but you know the
Prime Minister's going to have to link
arms with nicola sturgeon and Jeremy
Corbyn on that side of the army gonna be
a site not not a pretty picture I have
to say okay Liam Fox I could see thank
you very much indeed as ever